[Applaudissements]
mon
à la maman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
encore un exemple pour la jeunesse
d'être seule même Beyoncé avait été
accompagné elle a fait le concert tout
seul moi c'est ce que je vais exiger
très prochainement
et en fait ça vous partez comme c'est
gratuit le super ball c'est elle est pas
payée elle a obtenu et elle a pris le
droit de présenter sa marque de
cosmétique
en fait voilà c'est pas si bien dire que
moi qui ne connaissais pas honnêtement
c'est pas de ouf quoi c'est vu c'est
vulgaire c'est
[Applaudissements]
non mais alors c'est vrai que quand je
vois ta tenue aujourd'hui je me dis
c'est vrai que ça c'est moderne ça c'est
moderne c'est l'événement médiatique
c'est qu'on a retenu quoi quel était
enceinte et la fille qui fait la qui
faisait qui a fini pour la langue des
signes on en a ce que je vais faire
lesquels est-ce que je vais faire mon
prochain non je vais faire une cérémonie
que tu vas présenter le super boule
[Rires]
le plus grave c'est qu'en rihanna va
apprendre que Daniel Moreau
ça va ruer dans les brocards
et les papiers franchement
pour moi c'est la femme enceinte la plus
sexy du monde oui elle est extrêmement
vulgaire mais c'est ce qu'on attend de
Rihanna
elle est dans son rôle elle est dans son
personnage et moi je la trouve
magnifique elle est suggestive et donc
elle est très excitante elle est sexy
alors je vous dis la vérité sans
charrier rien là je l'adore c'est comme
artiste à mon délire encore
elle est charcutière tu la regardes
quoi j'ai la même j'ai la même personne
en bas de chez moi elle a ouvert un
petit magasin qui s'appelle le ryanus
[Rires]
je suis complet ah non
ce soir
il a raison non mais vous avez déjà
Léonardo Dicaprio je l'ai vraiment
croisé